nous avons eu il ya quelques semaines un
débat à l'assemblée nationale sans vote
imaginez sur une question aussi
essentielle que l'immigration on nous a
fait bavarder pendant plusieurs heures
sans que nous puissions voté quoi que ce
soit derrière et donc je vois bien la
stratégie d' emmanuel macron elle et de
bavarder largement sur ce sujet avec des
chiffres qui sont accablants on a une
augmentation de 20 % des demandes
d'asile dans notre pays depuis l'arrivée
d'emmanuel macron on a une baisse du
budget de lutte contre l'immigration
irrégulière de près de 10% cette année
ses 12 millions d'euros qui manquent au
crédit l'état vous voyez sur ce sujet
n'a pas droit de feld se remet seulement
se payer de mots il faut aussi se plaint
il va pas et j'apprends des mesures
demain un comité interministériel et et
devrait mettre à priori en place ces
quotas dans un pays comme le nôtre on ne
prend pas de mesures comme celle ci
seulement avec un comité
interministériel sera bon non c'est
ainsi qu'est ce que vous réclamez alors
que la loi c'est la loi qui doit fixer
les règles et ce qui pour moi le plus
grave encore c'est le niveau de cynisme
des manuels macron parce qu'au fond
emmanuel macron tout ce que je vous dis
là il le sait et son gouvernement ils le
savent ils savent qu'ils ne peuvent pas
faire ils savent qu'ils ne font pas et
même qu'ils ne veulent pas faire de ça
fait deux ans que c'est du vent qui est
un écart abyssal entre les mots et les
actes parce que sur ce sujet emmanuel
macron n'a pas de conviction